Sir David Attenborough has been making
Natural History films for the BBC for
over 50 years in this time he perhaps
more than anyone alive has seen evidence
for evolution in the stunning diversity
of nature define and film animals this
is the biggest flower in the world
induce on the planet in a new BBC
program called Charles Darwin and the
Tree of Life
Attenborough marks the bicentenary of
Darwin's birth and shares his personal
view of Darwin's brilliant but
controversial idea that all life is a
result of common descent by natural
selection in this interview for the
science journal Nature he talks about
the program and how the fact of
evolution has always been obvious to him
you would have to be extraordinaire
blinkered if you didn't stub your toe
against the theory of evolution very
early on in your life I mean if you
collect fossils which I did as a kid you
know that that ammonites changed as you
go up in the geological column evolution
is not just a theory as many a
correspondent writes to me and says it
is a historical fact like any other
historical facts and a certain as the
fact that William the Conqueror landed
in 1066 except that it's more certain
because it's the evidence for it's from
a much wider range of fact because of
course I can't remember a time when I
wasn't aware of Darwin to be honest I
know because it's written in my copy of
the origin that I bought them the origin
when I was 18 but I'm sure that I knew
about Wallace certainly when I was 14 or
12 it's not a bad graphical program is
not about Darwin's life it is about the
various objections which people in
Darwin's time and ever since Darwin's
time have found to accepting the
proposition of evolution so that in
Darwin's time geographical distribution
of animals was not understood the
mechanism of genetics was not understood
at all those are the sort of obstacles
which people over and over again said to
Darwin it can't be true because of these
reasons now the solution to those
questions have only been fully found in
my lifetime surprisingly recent I mean
we've only really understood about DNA
for for less
50 years we haven't understood about a
continental drift for 50 years the
reality the fact that the continents
have moved the special part most wasn't
proved even when I was an undergraduate
and I was at Cambridge and demanded from
our professor that he taught us about
continental drift he said I refused to
do so because though you can't
demonstrate that there is any any power
which will shift a constant per
millimeter all those those answers to
the obstacles the theory have any
recently been been out there but now
they are and and that together
cumulatively they validate Darwin's
insight to degree which we all ought to
be aware of the influence of of the book
of Genesis which says the Lord God said
go forth and multiply to Adam and Eve
and that the natural world is is there
for you to dominate you have dominion
over the animals and plants of the world
and that basic notion that the world is
there for us and that if if it does make
to serve our purposes its dispensable
that has produced the devastation of
vast areas of the land surface of course
it's a gross oversimplification but
that's why Darwinism and the factory
evolution it's a great important because
it is that attitude which has led to the
devastation of so much and we are in the
situation that we're in
you